[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
DERTOUZOS: Ladies
and gentlemen, there
is no reason we can't talk
about the future while having
a little fun.
So let me recollect
something for you.
Last year, a few of
my colleagues and I
were heading to Taiwan.
The flight as you
know, is very long.
And in the airplane, I was
trying to make something work.
Now that something
was a laptop--
brand new laptop, the latest.
It was running Windows.
And a little card on which
you download your software--
you download your addresses,
you download your calendar,
and then you take the
card in your pocket.
I had been at it
for three hours.
And my problem was that when
the card software was happy,
the operating system wasn't, and
vice versa, as you well know.
So we're in the plane.
So I turn to one of my
colleagues, and I say, Tim,
would you please help me?
Well Tim Berners-Lee
is a very gracious man.
So he said, of course.
He said, I think I can help you.
So he picks up the machine.
An hour and a half later,
he hands it back to me--
still very polite, still very
British-- says I'm sorry,
I can't make this thing work.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: So I turned to my
friend and associate director
Ron Rivest.
And I say, the inventor
of the web couldn't do it.
How about you?
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
DERTOUZOS: Inventor of RSA?
And Ron, with his characteristic
wisdom, looked at me and said,
no, Mike.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: And then the youngest
member of our delegation--
whose name I shall not mention
to protect the innocent--
jumped up.
And he says to me, you guys
are a bunch of old fogies.
Let me show you.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: Good LCS attitude.
Two hours later,
he hands it to me
with expletives
surrounding this.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: I went to my seat and
I did what every expert does.
I tried the various
wizards and lizards
that were coming up at me.
And I kept typing at
random things in the fields
until finally, three
hours later, it worked.
Total elapsed time nine hours.
AUDIENCE: Long battery life!
DERTOUZOS: [LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: Good point for
those who make batteries.
Now, ladies and gentlemen,
why do I bring this up?
Our field is young,
so I don't bring it up
to complain so much.
This is to be expected.
But we are at a junction.
What I experienced
with that example
is typical of what we have
done for the last 40 years
with our field.
We have focused on
designing for machines.
We put little envelopes.
We call them operating
systems, we call them browsers.
We call them network software.
And then we throw all
this stuff at the user.
Now the image that this
evokes to me is a user--
you-- sitting in your car, a
car that's very early vintage.
And you've got two
rings in every finger.
And on every ring
is attached a wire.
And you've got a wire
for fuel mixture.
You've got another wire for
advance of the ignition.
You've got another one for the
valve clearances, the brakes
and this and that.
And you're sitting there
with all these wires.
And we say to you, go
from Boston to New York.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this must stop.
40 years is enough.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
DERTOUZOS: This brings me
squarely into my vision
for the 21st century.
Stated in simple human
terms, it is simply this.
People should be able to
do more by doing less.
Now when I say
these simple words--
which have been characteristic
of every revolution up to now--
I mean three things.
First, we should bring the
technologies of information
into our lives.
Now when I read in the
papers and the magazines
and I hear the pundits talk
about cyberspace where we're
going to go-- this other space!
We're going to leave our
lives and go into cyberspace.
We're going to put on glasses--
gigabyte-infected suits.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: And we're going
to live in an exciting world.
Well, you know, when the
Industrial Revolution came,
we didn't go into motor space.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: The motors
came into our lives.
We turned them
into refrigerators.
And we called them
refrigerators, not motors.
We turned them into cars
and called them cars.
And they absorbed
themselves-- the motors did--
into the functions and tasks
that the ancient humans
have been doing except
now with new tools.
So the first thing is bring
the technology into our lives.
And that's exactly what
I think will happen--
and what I wish will happen--
with the Information Age.
They will come into our
lives-- the new technologies--
and they will serve
our ancient needs.
The second thing
that I mean when
I say doing more by doing less
is increased human productivity
and increased ease of use.
With respect to increased
human productivity,
first imagine that I'm
holding a Handheld Take
us to Athens this weekend.
Now, you'll see later a
system that does this.
It took me three
seconds to say that.
The computer knows
that us is two people--
but we like to travel
business class.
It knows the weekend is
Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
It connects with ease to Saber.
It starts doing the exchanges.
It tries for Friday.
It doesn't find an aisle seat.
We like aisle seats.
It goes to Saturday,
finds two seats,
but something else is wrong.
Finally books on Sunday.
Total elapsed time in
actual experiments for this
is minimum three minutes
maximum 13 minutes.
I will take five minutes
as an acceptable average.
Five minutes is 300 seconds.
Nod.
Divided--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: You went to Harvard
for a while, I thought--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: Divided by
the three seconds--
the 300 seconds--
it gives us a ratio
of 100 productivity leverage.
But in business
terms, that's 10,000%.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: We have
achieved a 10,000% increase
in human productivity.
Now this is actual.
Now, maybe I do it once a day
and you say it doesn't count.
But if I was the travel agent
for a large organization,
it would count.
Now I don't expect these kind
of gains across the board.
But I do expect across the
board in the next century--
and I explain this
in What Will Be--
about 300% increase
in human productivity,
primarily in the office sector.
Today, as you look
at your browsers,
as you look at
your email, you're
sitting there
exercising your eyeballs
and your brains just as hard
as our predecessors exercised
their shovels in
the Industrial Era--
except you're using
these for your shovels.
And shoveling you are!
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: But it isn't
painful because the shovels
are stamped high-tech.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: All right.
Let's take up ease of use.
Every time I hear the word--
the phrase-- ease of use from a
vendor of hardware or software,
I become physically violent.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: The invariable
image that pops up
is of their parading a
chimpanzee around dressed
in a green suit pretending
to be a surgeon.
I mean the thing
isn't easy to use.
The fact that they put
floating animals and colors
and ergonomics doesn't
make it easy to use.
What we want is something
that's truly easy
to use, regardless of whether
it's using graphics or text
or whatever.
Let me take an example.
Browsers and operating systems--
those two worlds-- one
catering to local information,
the computer, with
its computer system--
the other one catering to
long-distance information
across the browser--
have different commands--
quite different commands.
Now that doesn't
lead to ease of use.
The image I get from that
is that of an automobile--
again-- which, when
you're driving it
in your neighborhood--
local-- when you turn
right, it turns right.
But when you're driving
it on country roads, when
you turn the wheel right,
it applies the brakes.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: It sounds silly
here, but it sounds OK
when you highlight an icon
in the operating system
and take a hot link on the
browser with the same command.
So we've got to revise
this kind of stuff.
Now, ladies and gentlemen,
this is the second thing
that I mean when I
say that we should be
able to do more by doing less.
The third thing that I mean
is that when we say we,
we should mean the
people of the world.
Now we feel pretty
smug today because we--
the people of the
industrially wealthy world--
are largely connected.
But if you stop and look, there
are 600 million telephones
only, which is 10% of the 6
billion living on this earth.
And in term of these 600
million telephones, only 15%
are interconnected--
about 80, 90 million people.
Multiply the two--
1.5% to 2% percent of
the world's population,
ladies and gentlemen,
is interconnected.
That's all.
98% percent is disconnected.
We cannot hear the millions
of voices from the Indian
subcontinent, from Africa,
and from China-- although,
increasingly, they're
becoming connected there.
All we're getting is
the television feeds
and the government feeds.
And these people do not
have the opportunity
to sell their services
or their products
yet on the world's markets
through the new medium.
Now I think it's very
important to bring
these people in because,
left to its own devices,
the information revolution
will increase the gap
between rich and poor people.
The proof is
excruciatingly simple.
The rich get more computers.
They become more productive.
They get richer, The
poor have no computers,
stay where they are--
formula for exponential
gap increase.
Now everybody says, we
can help them to get out
of the problems, et cetera.
Yes, but we've got to help them.
Alone, they cannot get the
machines, the communications,
the training, and the
skills to do that.
It's important that we do so
not only for compassion's sake
and for altruism, but also
for self-preservation,
because history teaches
that when gaps like this
are allowed to grow,
they result in bloodshed.
So, ladies and gentlemen,
there's so much potential
if we do help the poor--
not only poor countries,
but poor people within
the rich countries.
The kinds of
services and products
they could sell, the way
they could rise, and--
it's not always helping
from the rich to the poor.
Imagine a Sri Lankan doctor.
A Sri Lankan doctor makes
$20 a day and speaks English.
Imagine that doctor connected
through the world's networks,
administering health care
to homeless people in Boston
could go to a kiosk
where there's a nurse,
there's a blood cuff
meter, a monitor.
They can talk to the doctor.
Maybe it's not the best
health care in the world
because the doctor isn't there.
But it's a lot better
than no health care.
And it might cost
$2 or $3 per person.
At the Lab for Computer Science,
a team of undergraduates
is building a virtual
Compassion Corps
that I discuss in What Will Be.
This is nothing more
and nothing less
than a gigantic want
ad website where
people who wish to give
human help and people who
wish to receive human help
find each other according
to the categories of help.
And they simply match
with each other and help.
First time in our history,
we could do this worldwide.
So-- to make it short--
the vision is to let people
do more by doing less.
And by this I mean three things.
First, bring the
technology into our lives.
Second, improve human
productivity and ease of use.
And third, include in this
vision all people of the world.
Good enough for
top level vision.
But now, over what
computing model
do we see this taking place?
Well, for the last
20 years, you've
heard me talking about the
information marketplace.
And I'm not going to change
my tune because we haven't yet
realized it.
So the model I am proposing
is the same model--
the information marketplace,
which I define as follows.
People and their computers--
about half a billion to a
billion in the next decade--
plus appliances, gadgets,
embedded computers
and the like that are unmanned
interconnected together,
doing three things--
buying, selling, and freely
exchanging two things--
information and
information services.
Now with respect to
buying and selling--
currently we're at $50 billion
per year on the Internet.
My estimate is $4 trillion
in the next 30 years or so.
Doing this by
going predominantly
down that half of the
industrial economy which
is called the office sector--
previously white collar work.
Half of our economy
is office sector.
And that is where the
bulk of it will come.
Now a big part of that is going
to be a new kind of activity
we haven't seen yet, which I
like to call office information
work.
See, we deal with
information as a noun.
Information as a noun is
text, sounds, images, videos.
Information is a verb
is what a doctor does.
It's what 1,000 accountants
do from Beijing, China,
when they sell their services
to General Motors in Detroit
for $2 an hour--
it is the processing, the
management, the handling
of information, the service.
That is going to be, I
believe, a very large part
of the information marketplace.
You add to that the
non-dollar component--
the family message links,
the political discussions,
the publishing, the
administration of health freely
where it happens, do-gooder
activities, chat groups,
neighborhoods-- all that
non-dollar huge component which
cannot be measured.
We cannot put a $4
trillion stamp on it.
But it's just as important.
And you have the picture of
this information marketplace.
We're not yet there.
There's no information work
on the current marketplace.
There is no automation.
There's no capability
to do collaboration.
All we're doing is we have
voyeurs exhibitionists--
[LAUGHTER] voyeurs
arousing, exhibitionists
are saying look at
what I'm selling.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: And a few little
transactions between them.
So we have a little bit of
ways to go before we get there.
Right.
So, let this be the vision
of doing more by doing less.
And let this be the
model over which
we will do more by doing less
in the information marketplace.
Now that's still pretty general.
So how might we do that?
What I would like to do next
is to announce a major research
project that we
are launching today
at the MIT Laboratory
for Computer Science.
We call it Oxygen. It's
a research project.
It involves a new--
radically new--
system for tomorrow
that contains a lot of this
stuff that I talked about.
I'm very happy to say that
oxygen went as a proposal $38.5
million proposal to DARPA.
And I'm very pleased to say
that DARPA awarded it to us.
But they haven't
awarded the money yet.
So we're negotiating that.
While I'm at it, let
me say-- you know,
we always say bad
things about government.
Let me say that in
the last 25 years,
I've led this laboratory.
And the 10 previous
years, DARPA has
been with us and with
other major universities.
And they've carved computer
science and technology
on the map.
And let me say that the current
efforts of the administration
to increase the funding
in computer science
and the various activities
that have happened there
are also laudable.
So we shouldn't always
complain about them.
They've been with us.
And this birthday is
largely due to them.
All right.
Oxygen. Now let me make
one more qualification
before I describe it to you.
You know, we're
not a corporation
with a smooth presentation
about a new system.
We have a framework.
Now, I'm not going
to be surprised--
because I'm certain--
that when we're
done, the thing will
be totally different from
what I described to you today.
As you hear the talks
of my colleagues, who
will speak about various pieces
of this, keep that in mind.
And as you hear the
talks of the others, who
will talk about other
things while pretending
to talk about the
pieces, keep in mind
that this laboratory does a
lot of independent research.
Keep in mind, too, that, as
we do all this systems work,
our eyeballs are
focused on trying
to understand the
fundamentals and the theories
behind this brave
new field of ours.
With that as background,
what is Oxygen?
Oxygen is 8 technologies,
which I will now enumerate
and describe very briefly.
Number one, the handy 21--
for 21 is for 21st century.
You see it has a
little display right
there is a little display,
which you can see.
If you're nearsighted, it helps.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DERTOUZOS: It's like
a cellular phone,
except that it has in it a
small screen, as you've seen.
It has a very small analog part.
The rest is all
digital, which means
it can change like a chameleon.
It's got an infrared detector.
And it's got, of course, a
few other odds and ends--
which permit it,
with downloading
to alter its function from
a two-way radio talking
to other such handhelds,
to a network node talking
to the campus network, to a
cell phone which sniffs the air
and decides I'm in France, so
I'm going to switch to GSM,
or it says I'm in
America, I'm using CDMA.
And on and on and on.
We have done this early
prototype in connection
with another DARPA contract
that Victor Zue and McCluskey
and Clark are involved in.
And maybe we'll
hear more about it.
But that is the first
technology of Oxygen.
What we're trying to do with
that is make sure that you have
a thing that is person-centric
wherever you go--
is with you.
In the symmetric form, the
second technology of Oxygen
is the enviro 21, which
is environment-centric.
It sticks to the wall--
actually, it's big, so it may be
in the wall or under the desk.
It's in the trunk of your car.
It's in your home.
It is in every respect like
the handy 21, functionally,
but it is much bigger.
So it bears a relationship of
a power socket to a battery,
if you wish.
Also, the enviro
21 has tentacles,
which are connected to
sensors and actuators
in the famous appliances
we're talking about.
And it can control them.
And also, the handy
has a little infrared
in it in our current vision.
And if you want to bring
this door into your world
you put an infrared
tag on the door.
And when you point
to handy to it,
the machine identity of the
door comes into your system.
And then you could bring
up a model that says,
these are the people
working behind it.
And this is what they're
supposed to be doing.
And you can go down
the corridor and check
what's behind every
door-- at least virtually.
So interesting
possibilities with Oxygen.
The third technology is N-21--
Network 21-- which is what we
have to add to the Internet
to make possible the
incorporation of these highly
mobile nodes called people
because the internet goes
to fixed addresses and we want
to go to resolve according
to intention.
It also makes possible
networks that rise and collapse
as people get together
for a meeting,
makes possible networks
of unknown elements,
fuzzy networks with
self-adaptation--
and we'll hear more
about this later on.
These are the three hardware
technologies of Oxygen--
with a lot of software
in them, of course.
The fourth technology
may surprise you
because it is an inner
hardcore technology.
It is built-in
speech understanding.
We really want our
machines to be easy to use.
We have to make them
interact with us naturally.
None of us is born with keyboard
sockets or mouse sockets
on our belly.
We're born with mouths and ears
and that's what we should use.
Dr. Zue's technologies are
fantastic at the narrow domain
level, as you heard
from Bill Gates.
What we are doing now
is stitching together
narrow domains to create
a broader listening
domain with some
human help so that it
can help us navigate through
these various narrow places
and still talk to it.
The handy 21 has no keyboard.
The fifth Oxygen technology
is individualized
knowledge access.
By this, I mean
that people should
be able to access knowledge
in ways familiar to them.
And we're talking about
low-hanging fruit here.
We're not talking about
high-falutin concepts.
You should be able
to say, get me
that red book next to the
blue one or next the document
that came from Paris yesterday.
And then if you run
out from your own store
of goods and knowledge, you go
to the store of your friends.
And you say, assuming
they permit you,
do you know the answer
to this question?
Can I access this from you?
And if that doesn't work,
you can go out to the web
and get the 5,000 hits.
But then in Oxygen, we
triangulate between those three
to try to tailor big
hits with friends
and individual knowledge.
The sixth Oxygen
technology is automation.
Now this is the
biggest workhorse
of the Information Age.
No revolution is
a true revolution
unless the machines
can do our work.
Take the shovels,
throw them away,
bring in the
electronic bulldozers.
That's what we want
with that technology.
In Oxygen we offer
scripts for you
to automate what
you're going to do.
And you can setup and
control procedures
that will take place
in a given time.
Or when something
arrives, you can
encapsulate physical
objects, deal with them
together with
informational objects,
and create a world
around you that
caters to you by offloading
work from your head and eyes
to the machines.
The seventh Oxygen
technology is collaboration.
And this you can
think of as a method
of keeping track of
meetings, a method of keeping
track of who said what--
open-issues-- and
a way of zeroing
in from human summaries, which
may be brief, to fragments
of speech that took
place in the meeting
all the way to original
work in the meeting that
will remind you, if you come
back later, of what you did.
The last, the eighth Oxygen
technology, is customization.
One of the most variable
resources in the world
is human beings.
And Oxygen enables us to
customize to individual needs.
Besides doing this in automation
and all the other technologies
I mentioned earlier, it does
this with all the software.
In Oxygen, there is no
shrink wrap software.
Everything is downloaded.
And everything is
adjusted according
to whether a user asked for
it or there was an error
or there was no
software made available.
This then, ladies and
gentlemen, is Oxygen. Handy 21s,
enviro 21s in the wall, and
Network 21, built-in speech,
individualized knowledge access,
automation, collaboration,
customization.
Now these eight are not
operating individually.
They're operating together.
And that's where
their power lies.
And now I'd like to
make a bigger claim.
When we envisioned that
person with the rings
in his finger trying to drive
from Boston to New York,
we were wishing that
we could give him
a gas pedal, a steering
wheel, and brakes
to make it easier to drive.
My claim is that the five
software technologies
of speech, individualized
knowledge access, automation,
collaboration,
and customization,
are essentially the new kids
on the block of the Information
Age.
That of the thousands
and millions of things
we read that will be
possible, a great deal of them
can be done with these five.
I believe these are pretty close
to the gas pedal, the brakes,
and the steering wheel--
at least for the next couple
of decades, or maybe earlier.
And if that is true, then
companies and individuals
will do well to ask
in their companies
and in their
activities, how can they
maximize their own activities
under these five elements?
Imagine a health
application under Oxygen.
What's the individualized
knowledge access?
Well, it's the doctor's
records, the patient records,
it's Medline--
all this has to be put
together, triangulated,
and help the doctors.
And then you can imagine the
collaboration when doctors get
together-- what they
will put on that--
and the customization
for individual doctors,
and the automation of
routine tasks for x-rays,
et cetera, et cetera.
So applications will take
their color from Oxygen
as applications have in the
past if our dreams come true.
Now I would like to close,
ladies and gentlemen,
by observing that both
my colleagues and I have
been immensely grateful
to work on this--
the information revolution--
for the last many, many years.
And we're very happy
and excited that we're
working on it right now
at this very moment,
at this very junction in change.
The vision of
doing more by doing
less on tomorrow's information
marketplace with Oxygen
as our first step is
where I see us today.
And since we're talking
about revolutions,
I'd like to close with an
observation and a wish.
All three revolutions
are based on things.
The Agrarian Revolution
was based on the plow.
The Information Revolution--
which is now happening--
is based on the computer.
And the one in the middle--
the Industrial Revolution--
was based on the motor,
the chemicals, so forth.
Well, maybe the
time has come for us
to start thinking of
a fourth revolution--
one that is not based
on things, but one
that tries to understand
the most precious resource
on our planet--
ourselves.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]